نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق الذي اعلن
ترشحه قال انه يامل في ان تفكر وزاره
العدل في الامر بشكل افضل وان تحل هذه
القضايا بدون لائحه اتهام
الجمهوري رونديس عبر عن اعتقاده بضروره
وضع معيار واحد للعداله
المرشحه الجمهوريه للرئاسه
الاتهام الفيدراليه ضد الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب تشير الى انه كان متهورا
بشكل لا يصدق في التعامل مع المعلومات
السريه
السيناتور عن الحزب الجمهوري عن ولايه
كارولينا الجنوبيه قال ان لائحه الاتهام
الفيدراليه ذات مزاعم خطيره
الامريكي من اصول هنديه والمرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه
لم يكن لياخذ هذه المستندات معه لكنه اكد
ان هناك فرقا بين الحكم السيء وخرق
القانون حاكم ولايه داكوتا الشماليه الذي
دخل السباق الجمهوريه تعهد باتباع كل
القواعد المتعلقه بالتعامل مع الوثائق
السريه بعد تركه لمنصب الرئيس المحتمل
الجمهوري جيم جوردن عن ولايه اوهايو قال
ان قدره الرئيس على التصنيف والتحكم في
الوصول الى معلومات الامن القومي تتدفق من
الدستور فهو وحده من يقرر
[موسيقى]